25 years old and we're talking about you
being a fashion icon
how does that sit with you
it's a little bit um
it's one of those things kind of you
know a dream and beyond my my
imagination so i don't know i it doesn't
feel quite real so i don't really know
how to answer the question i was saying
i was like i probably won't even absorb
the night until
a few weeks from now you know i i'm
still kind of living in a bit of a dream
so you always have law with you it's
like you know you two are two peas in a
pod when you first started working
together was it just like what were the
conversations like what were the you
know talking about fashion what you guys
wanted to do
um i don't know
one day be able to do this yeah you know
it was a goal for sure
absolutely yeah absolutely your most
iconic red carpet moments do you have a
couple favorites
oh man um
let's see i love the butterfly dress we
did uh teleport west plate i mean
there's so many
yeah i mean
we enjoy experimenting and having fun
and close our way that i get to do that
so i don't know it's like what are we
doing tonight
what are we doing tonight
yeah but what what's the what
are we giving what are we giving
you know
you know modern-day princess vibes if
you ask me yeah we've got the spider-man
press tour coming up what are you giving
us for that we're in the works
in the works
all right love it okay
[Music]